thank you everyone for attending my talk
today
my name is Anson Tariana I'm a medical
science liaison for genomic health
medical affairs group urology and today
my talk will be focusing on utilizing
MRI and genomic testing for the
treatment selection and early stage
prostate cancer now as a quick overview
of the epidemiology of prostate cancer
it's the most common non cutaneous
cancer diagnosed in men in the United
States with an average diagnosis volume
of one hundred and seventy four thousand
new cases this roughly translates into
one in nine men who are born today will
be diagnosed with prostate cancer in
their lifetime because of the this year
number of cases diagnosed it's actually
the second leading cause of cancer
cancer death and men in the US and it's
a tribute to over 30,000 deaths per year
now the the the problem with prostate
cancer one of the main challenges with
prostate cancer is that it's actually
considered an over diagnosed disease so
while there are a large number of deaths
that are attributed to prostate cancer
there's a much larger volume of patients
who are diagnosed with the disease and
treated for the disease but they aren't
necessarily dying from that disease and
so one of the primary challenges in
modern-day prostate cancer care is to
really separate or separate out the
patients who need immediate therapy to
to cure them of an aggressive form of
prostate cancer while identifying the
the majority men who don't need
aggressive cancer therapy or because
they they won't have a disease that all
affect their overall mortality now we
see this data bear out and a lot of
trials that that have been run to look
at the natural history of prostate
cancer so if we look in the SPC G for
trial this was a trial recruited that
began to enrollment in 1989 through 1999
and was really in the era before PSA
screening began to be put into clinical
practice in this particular trial we had
about 700 men who are divided into
a watchful waiting group which is simply
observation of the cancer after
diagnosis with no further intervention
and that was compared to a radical
prostatectomy group or the patients once
they were diagnosed with prostate cancer
went for immediate surgery now the the
the one thing to note about this group
of patients is that they had a much
higher disease burden than what we would
see in today's patient these patients
actually had palpable disease on digital
rectal exam and so they would typically
be a higher volume cancers as well as
higher grade cancers all that being said
these patients and especially in the
washable waiting group roughly 71% of
those patients were still alive at 15
years despite not receiving any sort of
therapy conversely despite having
received immediate surgery almost 20% of
men died at at year 15 an approximately
11% of men had benefited from from
actually receiving that surgery so again
we can see that there's already patients
in these early trials where they have a
large burning disease but can still live
for more than a decade despite not
having any sort of curative treatment
now after the SP cg4 trial had concluded
PSA screening had become more
implemented into standard clinical care
to find and detect prostate cancer
earlier in the in the disease course in
the ers PC trial we see that 13,000
patients were were studied with half the
patients going into a control group that
did not receive PSA screening while the
intervention group did receive PSA
screening at 13 years medium follow-up
we see that the control group hi excuse
me rather the intervention group that
had PSA screening had a 27% relative
risk reduction and mortality
what is what this translates into in
practical terms is that ninety-eight men
would need to be screened five prostate
cancers would need to be detected in
order to prevent one prostate cancer
death now there was certainly a
discernible benefit and doing this sort
of large-scale screen however the
authors authors themselves note that
there
were harms in doing this sort of
screening and particularly decided that
there was an over diagnosis and over
treatment of 45 cases and a loss of
1,100 life years free of prostate cancer
per 1000 cases essentially they're
saying that we're picking up clinically
insignificant disease and giving that
patient of cancer diagnosis even though
they wouldn't necessarily have been
negatively affected by that prostate
cancer within their lifetimes so the
authors to state that strategies are
actually needed to reduce over diagnosis
before generalized screening should go
into effect we see in this table that
there's a summary of multiple trials
over the course of the last 30 to 40
years as I mentioned earlier SPC G for
trial was in the pre PSA era when we
could see is that in the watchful
waiting or observation arm where the
patients didn't receive any sort of
intervention after their initial
diagnosis that the rate of death at 15
years was roughly 30 percent and the
incidence of metastatic disease after
that initial diagnosis was almost 40
percent and for this sir for the
patients that received surgery the the
rate of death was almost 20 percent and
the rate of metastatic disease was one
in four over 25 percent however you see
over time from SPC g42 the pivot trial
and which is the start of the early PSA
trial all the way down to the protec
trial which was our most recent data we
see that there was a multiple trends
happening one is that because the
prostate cancers were being caught
earlier because of PSA screening we see
that there the event rates for death and
metastasis are declining across all
cohorts
also we see that the Delta between the
outcomes in the observation group versus
the surgery a surgical intervention
group are actually shrinking
so going from 28% to 17% in SPC g4 in
pivot trial we see the Delta shrink from
that 11% Delta to about 4% and then in
projectile there's barely a recognisable
difference between
radical prostatectomy radiation therapy
or active surveillance however the
interesting thing is that in the
protract aisle where they actually
looked at active surveillance as as a
modality compared to radical
prostatectomy in radiotherapy there was
actually an increase in metastatic
disease for the after surveillance
cohort versus the immediate therapies of
radical mastectomy and radiation so
there is some work to be done here and
in order to continue to close that gap
for metastatic disease incidents and the
one thing to note between all these
trials is that watchful waiting no
observation can really be considered the
same sort of protocol where the patient
is diagnosed and then no further
treatment is done except to manage any
signs of progression but no actual
curative therapy is initiated and after
surveillance however the disease is
intentionally monitored over time so
rather than doing an immediate surgery
these patients are actually followed
routinely with biopsy or PSA and looking
for moments of disease progression at
which point they can actually switch
over and get a immediate therapy and so
because of protect I'll and because of
the other trials that I had just
discussed the the concept of active
surveillance had really taken hold as an
valid modality for for managing early
prostate cancer and the point of the
regret the purpose of active
surveillance are after monitoring is
really to minimize the risk of over
treatment by avoiding immediate radical
intervention however it's not
necessarily writing off intervention as
a whole it simply that will be
monitoring the disease and regular
intervals via 12 months 18 months or
perhaps longer and that we can initiate
actual curative therapy when it's deemed
necessary so the whole point of after
surveillance is to delay as opposed to
dismiss curative therapy and the the
benefit of doing this is that you can
maintain a patient's quality of life for
a longer duration while not negatively
impacting their oncologic outcomes so
one of the the goal really of modern
the cancer therapy particularly for
early stage prostate cancer is to
minimize the probability that prostate
cancer or it's actual treatment well
shorten a man's life expectancy or
impact his quality of life but also be
mindful of the cost of the care and the
treatment when selecting the optimal
approach all the different options that
are available for early-stage prostate
cancer do come with potentially
significant financial cost as well as
physical side effects when when you look
at after surveillance the least the
first year cost is approximately $900 a
year whereas a radical prostatectomy or
the various forms of radiation therapy
can go far beyond twenty to thirty
thousand dollars per year so ideally
when it comes to managing localized
prostate cancer we would like to to
treat only those cancers that have
metastatic or lethal potential while
putting everyone else on after
surveillance so we can monitor their
disease and then choose to treat them
when when there's some sort of clinical
indication to do so and based on all the
data that we just saw the national
guidelines committees have decided to
recommend after surveillance for a
subset of early-stage prostate cancer
specifically the a UA and NCCN
guidelines have noted that patients who
are considered very low risk or low risk
in terms of prostate cancer risk
recurrence would benefit from active
surveillance so very low risk and low
risks are typically patients with that
are picked up on PSA screening they have
low-grade disease with a low PSA and
also low tumor volume as in the the
number of cores that are found to be
positive with cancer are quite low
relative to the number of course taken
now while the guidelines were pretty
favorable about using active
surveillance in the very low and low
risk groups they were a little bit more
tentative when it comes to patients with
low volume but higher grade disease so
specifically the a UA and NCCN
guidelines said that it
clinicians can consider using after
surveillance and select patients with
favorable intermediate disease again
that would be low volume 3+4 disease and
we'll get into that a little bit more
later however they didn't necessarily
offer specific guidelines on how to
select for those patients so clinicians
are left to figure that selection
criteria for themselves different
institutions have put out different
their own versions of after surveillance
selection criteria however we can see
from here that they vary quite widely
depending on which institution you're at
the most conservative protocol that I
found was from Johns Hopkins which
really looked at very low volume low
grade disease with a very low PSA and
only a single core positive or excuse me
a less than two course positive whereas
the Royal Marsden Center and in the UK
actually has much more permissive
criteria where you can have t1 or t2
disease have a PSA up to 15 and can have
low volume 3+4 disease so this actually
spans quite a range where Johns Hopkins
only allows very instance E and very low
patients on to active surveillance
whereas we're all Marsden will actually
allow very low low and some favorable
intermediate patients on to active
surveillance so again there's a wide
range in terms of what people consider
to be patients who are eligible for
active surveillance now because there's
no real consensus on who to pick for
where at the active surveillance
protocol it should be no surprise that
we actually see a wide range of
variability across providers the data
here we see from the music consortium
out in Michigan it's a collection of 43
different centers both academic and
community who report out on their
prostate cancer patients in this
particular chart we see 13 different
centers all represented by the different
vertical histogram of vertical bars the
circles represent individual physicians
within a particular practice and the
size of the circle indicates the volume
patients with NCCN low-risk disease that
they might see and the y-axis to notice
the percent of those patients that are
put on actor surveillance so if we look
at the third bar which is a third which
is an independent clinical site they
have approximately ten physicians who
are practicing there and what we can see
is that two physicians who see roughly
the same number of patients who
clinically and pathologically look
identical they're all NCCN low-res 3+3
disease with low PSA despite the same
the same or two physicians in the same
site looking at basically identical
patients one of those physicians puts
60% of those patients on active
surveillance where the other physician
puts roughly 20% of those patients on
active surveillance so again a patient's
treatment selection can very very highly
based on where they're going and which
was is a physician they happen to be
seeing we also see quite a bit of
variability between countries in rate
active surveillance rates in Sweden for
very low and low-risk patients back in
2014 we're as high as 91% for very low
and 74% for low-risk patients this is
this is actually quite high especially
compared to the United States where only
40% of low-risk patients are receiving
after surveillance despite the fact that
NCCM guidelines recommend all of those
patients receive after surveillance as
their initial form of treatment if we
were to actually get that 40% closer to
the 74 percent like we see in Sweden we
would actually be able to add almost
20,000 patients to the after
surveillance treatment selection and
where they can actually defer or delay
that radical prostatectomy and
substantially increase their their
quality of life so all this data begs
the question what is preventing mass
adoption of active surveillance in the
United States and the primary driver
behind this is the lack of robust risk
stratification tools at our disposal so
particularly the needle biopsy is how we
diagnose prostate cancer
and because of the sheer nature of
needle biopsies and the fact that they
only sample less than 1% of the total
prostate volume we're left with
wondering whether or not what we're
seeing on the tumor excuse me what we're
seeing on the needle biopsy is really
reflective of what's going on in the
entire prostate gland
there's also patient and physician
reluctance again there's this
uncertainty about actual risk
classification based on the diagnostic
biopsy
there's also psychological factors like
the anxiety about inaction in choosing
after surveillance rather than doing
something immediately because of the
cancer diagnosis there's also the time
and effort required for prolonged
surveillance oftentimes patients have to
come into the office multiple times a
year I therefrom bye-bye you early PSA
checks or yearly repeat biopsies and
these repeat biopsies also come with
their own side effects in particular
sepsis or infection now before we go on
and discuss in the limits of the current
tools available for prostate management
I wanted to talk about Gleason score
grading the Gleason scoring system was
developed in 1966 by dr. Donald Gleason
and the PA research group and it's
really been a fantastic workhorse or for
the prostate cancer community in terms
of really characterizing a patient's
diagnosis and helping us understand how
aggressive more indolent a patient's
disease is originally the scale was from
1 through 5 and very similar to breast
cancer grading the higher the number the
the the poor the grade or and the worst
outcome for the patient however because
prostate cancer is a highly
heterogeneous disease unlike in breast
cancer where you have a single grade
grade 1 grade 2 grade 3 the pathologist
for a prostate cancer diagnosis have
asked to actually list the two separate
grades that are available on the that
typically are seen when diagnosing a
biopsy or a radical prostatectomy
specimen so there can often be time
of patterns that can be seen on the
tumor and so you can have pattern three
you can have pattern four and you can
have pattern but so in terms of Gleason
scoring what we see on the left hand
side is how these scores are reported
out on the pathology report so typically
you can see a Gleason score which is
anywhere at the lowest could be six all
the way up through ten but do you also
need to have the this coin breakdown
which is the the number right next to it
so in three plus three we know that the
dominant pattern is three and also that
any other secondary pattern is three so
this is essentially saying that the
patient has a homogeneous Gleason
pattern 3a throughout that clan and
therefore they have a total Gleason
score of six on the other hand for the
next two lines we see that the patient
has Gleason score seven however one line
says three plus four and the other line
says four plus three and this is where
really the distinction comes into play
and the second line where it says three
plus four the patient's dominant pattern
the majority of the pattern is pattern
three but however there is a minority
pattern of four that can be seen and
this suggests a hot much more higher
aggressive disease compared to a pattern
three plus three
if we go on to the third line where it
says four plus three this is even more
more aggressive pattern where the
patient has a majority pattern four and
a minor component of three so even
though they three plus four plus three
both equals seven four plus three
actually has the worst worst outlook and
we could see it on the far right hand
side in the end the biochemical
recurrence free progression so all of
this gets to be a bit confusing both for
for talking with and particularly in
talking with with patients about their
diagnosis patients that they hear that
the scale is from one to ten and their
lowest possible diagnosis is a six
they're automatically going to assume
that they might have much worse disease
than they actually have so in 2014
Jonathan Epstein and the isip group had
actually
rework the gleason scoring system to
make it a little bit more easier to
convey information and also to simplify
the nomenclature so rather than saying
three plus three or Gleason score six
they transformed it into these five
Gleason groups and or excuse me Gleason
grade groups so you can have great Group
one which is three plus three great
group 2 which is three plus four and so
on and they were revalidated to show
that they were predictive of biochemical
returns free progression now what's
interesting in terms of Gleason scoring
or and and the final prognosis for the
patient the Hopkins group actually took
a look at over 14,000 cases spanning
over 35 years where they looked at
purely all the great group one cancer is
the most Enderlin disease and they re
graded them on the more stricter 2005
isip criteria to look for just patients
with pure great group 1 disease and what
they found is that none of those
patients out of over 14,000 cases had a
lymph node metastases or distant
metastases and so what the authors
concluded based on this very large
retrospective review is that in order to
actually metastasize Gleason 4 or
Gleason 5 pattern needs to be present
within the patient's prostate so knowing
this it would in theory be very simple
to differentiate between who as
metastatic non-lethal disease and who
has indolent disease as long as we know
the patient has pattern 4 or pattern 5
disease they clearly would need surgery
and the rest of the patients can go on
takt surveillance unfortunately the only
way to know what's in the prostate is to
actually take out the prostate in which
case definitive or curative therapies
already done and we can't necessarily
rely on that needle biopsy this
retrospective review of 8,000 cases from
Mayo Clinic Rochester shows that and
inked in in 20 percent of cases where
the patient has 3 plus 3 on the needle
see I'd surgery the patient actually had
much higher grade disease and again in
20% of cases where the patient had 3+4
disease on biopsy they actually had much
lower grade disease and so we can't
reliably use or the needle biopsy to
help us understand what's truly in the
prostate because of the sheer nature of
how prostate cancer manifests which it
tends to be multifocal and also
heterogeneous in terms of tumor grade so
we know that our current tools are have
their limitations in terms of being able
to risk stratify so a lot of researchers
were looking at actually building new
tools to to better risk stratify
patients and low and intermediate risk
prostate cancer and in terms of building
a more effective tool we needed a reach
three criteria we needed something that
has that predicts a clinically
actionable endpoint it needs to add
value beyond the traditional markers
such as a tumor volume Gleason grade PSA
status and then also it needs to address
the inherent hetero heterogeneity of
prostate cancer both in terms of tumor
grade this year in fact that the that's
multifocal in nature and then also a
biopsy under sampling so if we look at
the image on the right if the patient
were to have the standard 12 or trust
biopsy of the transrectal ultrasound
biopsy the patient may not or the
physician may not necessarily see that
very small high-grade focus on the far
right hand side and may only hit with
the one or two biopsy needle is the
low-grade focus on the left hand side
and without knowing that the the
high-grade focus existed this patient
could in theory be sent to after
surveillance even though they're
harboring aggressive disease so
typically prostate cancer in terms of
outcomes and endpoints we Bo we tend to
focus on overall survival and disease
specific survival however for low and
intermediate risk
these they're not particularly
particularly useful endpoints do the
long natural history of prostate cancer
there's actually very low events when it
comes to death in this sub population of
prostate cancer people have attempted to
look at intermediate endpoints such as
metastasis free survival and metastasis
free survival has been identified as a
robust intermediate and point for
localized prostate cancer but those
prostate cancers all tend to be high
risk so there are higher grade higher
volume' disease that not that are not
classified by the NCCN as being low or
favorable intermediate and again
metastasis like deaths there are too few
events but in the low and favorable
intermediate groups for those to be
useful in terms of clinically risk
stratifying these patients again if you
look at the protect data at 10 years
there is less than there was only 1% to
one and a half percent rates of death
for active surveillance or surgeries so
you're not going to be able to really
risk stratify patients based on based on
this end point and again protect had
largely low and intermediate risk
patients within their cohort and for
metastatic disease at most at ten years
you'll see a 6% rate of metastasis and I
would argue that there's not much to
risk stratify here in theory if you were
to have a tool that risk stratified
based on metastasis alone patients that
had a 5 or 6 percent rate of metastasis
would go to actu surgery whereas
patients with a 4 percent or less may go
on after surveillance but clinically
speaking is there much of a difference
between a patient with 4 percent risk of
metastases versus a 5 percent risk of
metastasis and if you were to ask that
patient that they may not necessarily
have a consistent opinion from patient
patient so because endpoints like
overall survival and metastasis free
survive are not necessarily as useful in
low in favor point or immediate risk
populations we're going to look at
another near-term endpoint which is
adverse pathology and the researchers
from the University in Michigan actually
looked at a 2,800 cases and attempted to
look at various combinations of adverse
pathology to determine what was most
prognostic and what they found was
definitions for and definitions five had
the best hazard ratio in terms of
predicting biochemical recurrence in
patients and further analysis definition
five which is a combination of high
grade disease and non oregon combined
disease so t3a is extra capsular
extension t3b seminal vesicle division
if you have either high grade disease or
non oregon confine disease you would see
the most reclassification of patients
into into risk groups that had the
strongest prognosis or were most
associated with biochemical recurrence
and so again they found that adverse
pathology using the specific definition
of in definition v which is again high
grade disease and non core organ
confined disease was your best bet in
terms of identifying patients at higher
risk for for bad outcomes and we see the
the analysis from the University of
Michigan researcher is being confirmed
in the literature itself if you look at
various large cohorts where they look at
outcomes for patients the patients that
have adverse pathology at respectively
tend to have much higher rates of all
endpoints so they have lower
progression-free survival times they
have higher rates of biochemical
recurrence metastases and prostate
cancer specific mortality whereas
patients who had lower favorable
intermediate risk disease at biopsy and
went on to radical mastectomy if they
had favorable pathologies low-grade
disease or can combine disease they had
much lower rates of failure and so
because of this because adverse
pathology seems to be a much more nearer
term endpoint that can
take the longer-term outcomes new risk
stratification tools have been designed
to to be used to predict this adverse
pathology endpoint so for the rest of
talk we'll be focusing on MRI magnetic
resonance imaging as well as genomic
testing and in terms of multi parametric
MRI the the point of the testing is
really to provide a visual assessment of
of the disease so getting a better
understanding of the geography of the
disease and there's a an Associated
scoring system that can give you the
probability of high grade disease
genomic testing rather than giving you a
visual assessment provides you a
molecular assessment of the underlying
tumor biology and genomic tests are
designed to be associated with different
relevant clinical end points such as
adverse pathology biochemical recurrence
metastasis and death as well and they're
also designed to be independent of
clinical pathological areas so in terms
of how multi parametric MRI works what
happens is the patient enters the MRI
machine and a magnetic field it's turned
on the magnetic field causes all the
protons to reorient and align to the
field itself at that point while the
magnetic field stays on a radiofrequency
pulse is put out that flips it to be
against the rug the magnetic field this
causes a strain on the proton the pulse
is then turned off at which point energy
is released and the proton realigns with
the magnetic field so it's this constant
pulsing of putting the proton into a
strain position and then releasing it
that allows for an image to be captured
and then analyzed in the software to to
render a visualization of what's going
on in the prostate and the energies
released and then in terms of the
intensity and the nature of that energy
is a varies depending on the tissue
which is why you can get a
differentiation between the cancer
tissue and the normal tissue MRI itself
is used in multiple clinical settings it
can be used before the biopsy and while
it's not necessary
diagnostic it can give physicians a
better idea of whether or not the
patient's harboring regions of interest
that might be holding clinically
significant cancers that need to be
biopsied of course that's really in the
clinical trial setting and not
necessarily used in the clinic clinic or
routine practice well we'll be focusing
on is using the MRI during the pre
primary treatment phase where the
patient is having a biopsy and we want
to target specific regions of interest
to make sure that we sample is great
disease and also in to a lower degree in
the surveillance cohort where the
patient is diagnosed and choose zappa
surveillance and we're monitoring them
for further disease progression in order
to standardize standardized MRI
assessment the pie-rats system which was
created which is the prostate imaging
reporting and data system and this was
really designed to focus on the
likelihood of finding adverse pathology
and their adverse pathology definitions
a little bit different rather than four
plus three disease that we saw in the
kozminski paper that I mentioned earlier
the pirate system really looked at three
plus four disease and also disease that
was higher than 0.5 ccs as well as extra
prostatic extension the scoring system
itself is from 1 through 5 the one being
highly unlikely a finding this sort of
clinically significant disease and five
being highly likely that the disease is
present again MRI itself is not
necessarily diagnostic of the disease
but it can point physicians to the right
to the right area to actually sample and
also give them a general idea of what
they're likely to find so MRI is made up
of three separate components there's the
t2-weighted image which really looks at
the fatty tissue and water-based tissues
in the body differential weighted
imaging excuse me diffusion weighted
imaging which looks at the motion of
free water within tissue and then also
dynamic contrast enhancement which is
really looking at the vascularity or the
leakiness of the blood vessels
within the prostate and the tumor and
changes within the normal tissue and
cancer tissue can be spotted based on
these different qualities of the
different images and radiologists can
look between all three images to
identify the areas that they find to be
suspicious and assign a score to those
areas so depending on which zone of the
prostate we're looking at different the
different imaging components hold
different weight 70 80 % of all prostate
cancers are found in the peripheral zone
and in those cases the
diffusion-weighted image it holds the
highest weight and the dynamic contrast
enhancement image is really used to
separate out between pie-rats 3 and
pie-rats wore in the transition zone
where - about 20% of prostate cancers
are diagnosed the t2-weighted image is
what really drives the pirate score and
the only difference that are the early
differentiation that diffusion weighting
image offers is between pirates 3 and
pirates 4 and really the point of this
is to really highlight the fact that
pirate scoring is really predicated on
one particular image and it's important
to get a high quality image in order to
do accurate pirate scoring in terms the
NCCN guidelines MRI can be used for
patients when they're considering
staying on active surveillance so you
can use MRI to confirm a patient's candy
for candidacy for active surveillance
and also in terms of monitoring disease
progression if you see a patient go from
a pirate 3 to potentially a pie-rats 5
that's suggestive of higher grade
disease now that doesn't necessarily
take a patient off of active
surveillance by itself however would
trigger a physician to likely re biopsy
that patient - especially and biopsy
that pie-rats 5 area to determine if
there's higher grade disease within the
oregon but the but the NCCN does
highlight that no prayer
including changes to the MRI are very
reliable at detecting a disease
progression and will see the data in the
next few slides as to why that is so
overall there's actually many dozens if
not hundreds of studies looking at MRI
and how while they perform at finding
high-grade or non oregon combined
disease and the consistent theme from
all the data is that MRI targeted
biopsies are much better at finding
clinically significant disease while
missing clinically in significant
disease compared to the twelfth course
systematic trust biopsy so again in
general they MRI targeted biopsy can
identify disease that we should worry
about so the three plus four and above
or and specifically missed they're three
plus three disease whereas the twelve
core biopsy tends to pick up all these
cancers and especially those three plus
three diseases that you don't
necessarily need to worry about in terms
of patient and managing the patient's
care MRI is good but not great at
finding all clinically significant
disease while the page while M MRI has a
high negative predictive value the
positive predictive value actually
varies quite significantly anywhere from
sixty to ninety percent and because of
that variability there's there's some
false negatives and false positives that
happened that we'll see in the next
couple of slides so again this this
study that was noted or cited in an NCCM
guideline shows that MRI performs quite
well in detecting larger grade a larger
volume disease and and tumor that's over
five millimeters and also in higher
grade disease specifically in Gleason
four plus four and above and we noticed
that the sensitivity actually dropped
substantially when you're looking at a
lower grade disease at Gleason seven and
below and also disease that's smaller in
terms of volume so five millimeters
below the sensitivity actually drops
across all MRI components all that being
said
we still have great level-one be
evidence that shows that MRI it
definitely improves the detection of
clinically significant disease in the
promised trial that enrolled about 740
men 576 of them all underwent an MRI
followed by MRI targeted biopsy trust
biopsy and also TPM biopsy which is
total prostate mapping in other words
this is the saturation biopsy it
actually takes anywhere from 50 to 90
cores from the prostate so this
technique is not typically used in a
routine patient care but however it is
used in some clinical trials and it's
believed to be as effective if not
better than radical prostatectomy simply
because in total prostate mapping
biopsies you can to map patients who
have very low risk and low risk disease
who wouldn't necessarily go to radical
prostatectomy so remove some of the bias
from looking at adverse pathology
outcomes and radical prostatectomy in
this particular trial well clinically
significant disease was defined as
having four plus three or above or also
having a higher volume of disease in
terms of having six millimeters or more
on any particular core and in terms of
negative predictive value the MRI
actually has a 89% negative predictive
value which means that if a patient has
a pie-rats
two or pie-rats three score they are
likely not to harbor any sort of high
grade disease here's the more granular
breakdown of the data so in 576 MRIs
about 27% 158 we're called PI rads one
or two and the vast majority of those K
of the 158 141 cases they found no
cancer or clinically insignificant
cancer on saturation biopsy so
essentially the the majority of these PI
rads one and two is correctly called
that the patient was not harboring in
significant disease however in 10% of
the PI rads one in two cases there was
clinically significant disease that was
considered to be
on the flip side of the 576 mr i--'s 418
patients had a pirate's three or above
and which would suggest that the
patient's harboring higher-grade disease
however out of those 418 positive calls
only 213 actually had significant cancer
which means that 205 over half the
patients that had a positive
quote-unquote call for for harboring
significant disease ended up showing no
significant disease or no cancer at all
so while they while MRI does have a high
negative predictive value it actually
has a much lower positive predictive
value in this particular study only
about 56% which is really no better than
a coin flip if we look at the precision
trial this in this particular study we
looked at patients who underwent MRI
targeted biopsies versus trust biopsies
and only patients that had pie-rats
three or above actually underwent biopsy
and what we see is that again you see
this continuing theme where mr I guided
biopsies were better than trust biopsies
at finding higher grade disease while
ignoring lower grade disease and again
we we see that MRI has much lower rates
of coleen 3+3 disease whereas standard
the standard 12 core trust biopsy was
actually finding a lot more 3+3 disease
and really should should be detected so
in terms of applying this data to the
clinical setting it seems reasonable to
take all patients who have pie-rats one
or two lesions who also had a three plus
three on their biopsy to conclude that
they are not harboring aggressive
disease and of course this call would
really need to be made
assuming that the PI reg 1 and 2 score
was being called up by an experienced
radiologist as we noted that there is a
high learning curve and actually doing
pirate school
in a way that's consistent to all these
clinical trials if a patient has Peyer
edge three four or five and they have a
three plus three or three plus four
finding on their biopsy they'll likely
need to have additional information
before you can actually make the
competent treatment decision in terms of
MRI being able to detect non organ
confined disease we see that the the
negative predictive value actually
varies in terms of how how good MRI is
overall the negative predictive value is
a little less than 70% for MRI however
if you look at just purely low-risk
patients the negative predictive value
actually gets closer than 90% so in a
very select cohort of low-risk patients
MRI tends to be at identifying the
absence of t-38 disease however the
caveat again is that you need a highly
experienced radiologist to make the call
if you look at a systematic review by
the Cochrane review of 43 different
studies they created a model that looked
at how the frequency of false negatives
if patients were used MRI targeted
biopsy versus systematic biopsy I'm not
going to go into this slide in any
particular detail but I just wanted to
point out that if you looked at patients
that who used MRI and for for their
targeted biopsy for diagnosis there was
an 8% false negative rate whereas if you
were to use a 12-course systematic
biopsy there was an 11% false negative
rate so again there is a consistent miss
across the different types of biopsies
in terms of calling or miss calling
clinically the absence of clinically
significant disease so in terms of where
we're at with multi parramatta camera
MRI in terms of strengths the MRI is
really good at ruling out in significant
disease because of its high negative
predictive value and it is superior to
trust biopsies in terms of finding
clinically significant disease and again
while overlooking insignificant disease
it does have the potential to reduce the
number of biopsies needed in certain men
we're not necessarily there yet in terms
of using MRI before their first biopsy
to decide who should get a biopsy and
who doesn't but I feel like the the data
is marching in that direction now in
terms of limitations there is a wide
variability in PPV and NPV data for MRIs
ability to find clinically significant
disease so while again MRI tends to be
good at ruling out clinically
insignificant disease there is still a
wide range in its ability to actually
find clinically significant disease and
so and that's largely due to variability
in terms of equipment and operator and
so there's a significant deliberate
learning curve as well as inter and
intra observer variability MRI seems to
consistently miss at least ten percent
of clinically significant disease and
arguably pie Reds may be using a
suboptimal definition of adverse
pathology because again they based it
off of the presence of three plus four
above disease wherever whereas we've
seen another research that four plus
three and above disease might be the
better definition for adverse pathology
so switching over to genomic tests
genomic tests look at the molecular
biology of the teeth of the disease
rather than taking a visual approach so
genomic tests typically use tissue
that's already been retrieved from the
patient either through the diagnostic
biopsy or subsequent surveillance biopsy
a small piece of that tissue is
extracted for RNA and analyzed using
different methodologies such as rt-pcr
or microarray the expression levels for
a preset Bank of genes is measured and
normalized and then runs were clinically
about a validated algorithm to produce a
result that then a physician can use to
guide treatment selection so there's a
several different commercially available
tests the most popular are the following
three the pro lares tests which is a 46
gene a say the decipher test
the 22 gene assay and the Oncotype DX
GPS test which is a 17 gene assay for
the purposes of this talk we'll only be
talking about the last two again and
we're looking at comparing genomic tests
and and MRI and since MRIs looking at
adverse pathology will also be discussed
in decipher and Oncotype DX which also
have adverse pathology as their
endpoints too it should be noted just
like MRIs including the NCCN guidelines
molecular testing is also listed as
being something that should be
considered for both low-risk patients as
well as favorable risk patients and the
most recent NCCN guidelines first we'll
take a look at the decipher test this is
a 22 gene panel that was developed by
genome D X and originally was designed
to look at the prediction of early
metastasis and in terms of the assay
development do they used RP samples or
radical prostatectomy samples where they
specifically micro dissected the highest
grade focus and did their gene discovery
using the highest grade of cancer
available on the under radical
prostatectomy and they have had multiple
validation studies which show that there
there scores associated with predicting
the risk of high grade disease at
radical mastectomy as well as metastasis
at five years after a mastectomy and ten
years
excuse me death at ten years after cost
ectomy as well their score is from zero
to one
with low res being from zero to 0.45 and
high risk from 0.6 to one and that will
give you a school or the scores are
typically associated with a percent risk
of the following outcomes high grade
disease metastasis and 10-year survival
so for the purposes of this talk I won't
necessarily go into all the different
validation studies for each of the
genomic tests however they've all been
clinically validated for their various
clinical endpoints that they're looking
at for this particular talk we'll be
looking at the performance of these
genomic
test results in the context of MRI
guided biopsy in this particular pilot
study we see that and the authors looked
at the transcriptome wide analysis of
MRI targeted biopsies and matched them
to the radical prostatectomy in about 27
patients what they found was that as
long as you tested on the highest-grade
needle biopsy available you get an 80
through 83 percent concordance in
decipher score between the sample and
the and the radical prostatectomy there
was a much lower concordance way if you
were to use a lower grade biopsy when
you compared to the to the decipher
score generated from the radical
prostatectomy and this is likely due to
the fact that their original development
and validation work really focused on
using the the highest grade tumor from
the radical prostatectomy in the same
study if we look at how the decipher
results looked across different pirate
score we actually see a clustering of
results so all the low deciphered scores
clustered around high reg 1 and 2 and
all the high Discoverer
deciphered scores clustered around
pie-rats 5 now the initial look at this
data of this small pilot study would
suggest that there's no real utility and
using one test over the other or rather
there's no real utility and using both
tests combined you can either use one
test or the other because they seem to
both predict each other however if you
look at a larger study of a hundred
patients you actually see a much larger
variation and disguise and deciphers
score results across different pirates
and Gleason scores so in patients with
high rads of 1 2 or 3 and 3 plus 3
disease or Gleason grade one you can
actually see both low risk and high risk
scores and again we see that in Gleason
grades 2 pi rads 1 2 3 and 4 and 5 as
well so this would suggest that there is
actual utility and using
the decipher test in addition to the MRI
guided biopsy to get a better
understanding of the patient's potential
for for aggressive disease in terms of
the genomic prostate score the GPS test
this was a 17 gene panel as I developed
by genomic health and it was designed
from the start to look at adverse
pathology at radical prostatectomy so
again high grade disease non organ
confined disease and in terms of gene
selection for the development of the
study they actually looked at both the
highest pattern as well as the dominant
pattern and the point of doing this sort
of gene discovery was to to mitigate the
the likelihood that tumor heterogeneity
will affect the score itself so they
were looking at school genes that were
expressed both in the highest pattern
disease as well as the dominant pattern
disease so and that had equal weight in
terms of prognosis regardless of which
pattern you hit and subsequent data has
shown that the GPS score very is very
little depending on which which tissue
you test which would suggest that the
heterogeneity may not necessarily be as
large of an issue for this particular
test in terms of the real utility of the
test if you look at NCCN risk groupings
the NCCN very low risk group buckets all
patients is having an 84 percent
likelihood of having favorable pathology
at radical prostatectomy so for all
comers if you're listed as very low risk
you would just assume that have an 84
percent chance of having good pathology
at a radical prostatectomy
conversely if you're in CC an
intermediate risk you had a flip of a
coin a chance in terms of having our
ring good or bad pathology what's useful
in terms of risk stratification is
applying a genomic marker to these
buckets or classifications and you can
actually see the actual underlying
spectrum of risk these individual
patients might have so a patient can
have
intermediate risk disease however their
likelihood of favorable pathology say if
you had a GPS of a flood could be as
high as 75 percent chance of having good
pathology no aggressive disease or you
can have as low as 30% chance which
means that there's a very high risk of
actually harboring high risk disease and
again the interesting thing is here is
the actual overlap between the different
risk groups with switches which would
suggest that despite these patients
having different volumes of disease and
different Gleason scores of disease they
could biologically actually function
quite similarly due to each other and
because of this would there's belief
that we can actually find those patients
that actually have biologically indolent
disease as a fee as opposed to
phenotypically indolent disease in terms
of the test results the results would go
from 0 to 100 and they allow for a
patient to be reclassified from their
clinical pathologic NCCN risk group to a
combination GPS NCCN risk group so they
can either stay consistent with their
clean path risk group or they can be
quote unquote upgraded or downgraded to
another risk group and this helps
physicians determine whether the patient
actually is harboring worse disease than
they actually suggest on the first page
and the very last number is the percent
risk of adverse pathology for this
particular patient they have a 15% risk
of adverse pathology and on the second
page of the report you can see where
that patient falls in terms of their
biologic score compared to the rest of
patients that also have and she's in low
risk disease and the validation studies
so this patient has a particularly low
risk type of disease since since they
appear to be on the tail end of the
distribution the individual components
of risks of adverse pathology are listed
on the second page as well
this patient has a nine percent risk of
high grade disease and a 10 percent risk
of non-organic online disease and again
on the first page they have that 15
percent chance of having one
or the other in terms of the Oncotype DX
GPS test performance in the MRI targeted
biopsy setting a cohort from UCSF of a
hundred patients were a were looked at
and what they wanted to see in this
study was whether or not there was an
association between MRI findings of the
pirate score and the GPS result and the
authors originally hypothesized that the
pirate score would be strongly
correlated with the with the GPS results
so that the higher the pirate score the
higher the GPS result interestingly
enough in this study they rather than
finding a strong Gloria correlation they
actually found a weak correlation
between pirate score and GPS results
this wide distribution of GPS results
within each pirate score would suggest
that there's actually a wide range of
biology contained within these separate
GPS scores and that would suggest that
the GPS result is actually providing
information that's independent to the
pirate score and again the result is
validated to predict adverse pathology
and oncologic events independent of
other pathology assessments and this
seems to be consistent with other
findings so again we can see that the
GPS result is show does have a wide
range regardless of pirate score and as
well as a Gleason score and so there's
no clustering effect that's necessarily
seen although there's these are small
numbers this will probably need to be
confirmed on subsequent larger studies
so again in terms of the conclusion for
this study there was only a weak
correlation found between MRI pirates
chlorine and GPS testing which would
suggest that both systems represent
independent predictors of outcome and
the wide overlapping distribution of GPS
value would suggest that there's there's
value in doing testing in addition to
MRI target biopsy now again while we see
a range of biology we need to see data
on whether or not the the genomic
testing
is actually useful in predicting adverse
pathology above and beyond what MRI
targeted biopsies can do and so in this
study 134 patients from UCLA the authors
were looking at just that whether or not
the GPS test can predict adverse
pathology in the setting of using MRI
targeted fusion biopsy to theoretically
target the highest grade disease so can
GPS add more information in terms of
predicting bad disease over what MRI is
supposed to do which is predict bad
disease and so again like the previous
study we see a range of GPS scores
across each pirates core so there's no
clustering so this again would suggest
that there's a an independent amount of
information that's being provided by GPS
and if you look at the modeling that was
done the area under the curve was
highest when you actually combined
Gleason score GPS and highest pirate
score and that a UC was 0.79
interestingly enough if you take away
the pirate score and just look at
Gleason score and GPS the area under the
curve is also 0.79 whereas if you look
at Gleason score and higher as hires
pirates or by itself it's point six nine
so this data would suggest that GPS
certainly adds information to Gleason
score and pirates score but pirate score
doesn't necessarily add further
information than just simply having
Gleason score and GPS result so again
this shows that the genomic testing
really is complementary to MRI guy MRI
targeted biopsies in terms of
surveillance we actually see that the
UCSF had recently published a study
looking at how patients perform in the
active surveillance setting so this
particularly looks at GPS scores pirate
scores and whether or not men are
upgraded on subsequent biopsy so all
these men had 3+3 disease that were put
on after surveillance and were
subsequently biopsied and the authors
were looking for whether
there was a biopsy upgrade from 3+3 to
higher grade disease and what they found
is that if you look at the 25th
percentile which is a GPS of 16 the
majority of patients did not have a
biopsy upgrade so their their Gleason
score stayed as a 3 plus 3 from their
initial diagnosis to their subsequent
confirmatory biopsy however if you
looked at GPS of 29 and above those
patients did have a trend towards a
biopsy nightime much excuse me upgrade
in a much higher rate so if you had a
GPS of 29 or above those patients had a
much higher likelihood of finding 3 plus
4 or worse disease on confirmatory
biopsy and we found that this effect of
the GPS test being more predictive than
pie-rats and multi variable analysis so
what we found was that the GPS test if
he had a score of 29 or above there was
a 2 and 3 chance of a patient failing
after surveillance within three years
and so this data would suggest that a
patient who has a high enough GPS result
because they do have a high likelihood
of failing active surveillance because
they would have a biopsy upgrade they
may want to discuss do any immediate
therapy rather than wait the three years
whereas if you have a low GPS of 16 or
lower within three years there's a 75%
chance of not finding any higher grade
disease and so patients and physicians
can be more comfortable with the fact
that they'll likely be able to stay on
active surveillance for at least three
years and these GPS cut-offs actually
outperform the PI rad score one through
four vs pie-rats five and the authors
conclude again that it may be reasonable
to use GPS and shared decision-making to
determine who benefits from active
surveillance and that patients who have
a GPS of higher than 29 are more more
likely than not to fail active
surveillance in three years
so in review in terms of strengths
multi-gene signatures have been shown
schon underlying biology cannot be fully
assessed by phenotypic markers so this
includes clean path features as well as
imaging the the added strength of
genomic testing is also that it's
centralized and its objective in terms
of its measurement with minimal
variability and you can see those in the
analytic validation studies for each of
the assays
there's also a much lower threshold for
adoption and and implementation there's
there's no capital expenditure in terms
of getting an MRI the the equipment and
also training the the staff as well
there's also ever growing clinical
validation utility data coming out for
genomic tests in terms of limitations
there is limited data or how useful
these tests are an MRI targeted biopsy
setting however more data is to come in
the in the next few years on that and
there's no long-term outcomes and after
surveillance populations so well that
previous UCSF data that had just shown
was the first of its kind and then after
surveillance population it was only for
a couple of years and we need the
longer-term outcomes to see how well
genomic tests can help and risk stratify
these patients and then lastly there's
no their rather little health economic
data in terms of stand alone versus
combined use of MRI and genomics to see
what's most cost effective in terms of
combining both genomic testing and MRI
in low and intermediate risk patients
for practices that are already using MRI
target biopsies MRI really should be
sufficient in an inin by itself if a
patient has low pie-rats score so
specifically a PI reg 1 and 2 and they
have a 3 plus 3 on their biopsy based on
all the data that we just looked at as
well as a significant amount of data in
the literature these patients are not
likely harboring higher grade disease
now if a patient has a 3 plus 3 on
biopsy and they have a pie-rats 3 4 or 5
they would benefit from genomic testing
because again the positive predictive
for pi res 3 4 or 5 is not that great
and it's not entirely known whether or
not the patient actually had the the
highest grade actually sampled and the
same issue also exists for 3 plus 4
biopsies again there's a there's a
controversy on whether or not 3 plus 4
patients all have clinically significant
disease and there's a subset of these 3
plus 4 patients that do go on after
surveillance so simply finding 3 plus 4
on biopsy does not necessarily give you
enough information to make a treatment
decision between the immediate therapy
and after surveillance and for practices
who are only using the 12 course
systematic biopsy it becomes highly
context dependent on which methodology
to use I would offer that genomic tests
typically have a lot of patient
assistance programs to reduce financial
talks to see for patients and they also
present with minimal logistical
challenges for the patient they would
already had the biopsy and the biopsy
would be available at the pathology
office so there's no other additional
visits or interaction that would need to
take place to get a genomic test done
for those patients so in terms of future
directions we still need larger studies
to clarify what the full range of
genomic test results are for each
pie-rats group or parrot scoring group
and then we'd also like to have
confirmatory studies showing that GPS
results as well as other genomic test
results are still informative in the MRI
targeted biopsy context and specifically
improving area under the curves results
there'd also be a need for health
economic analysis to determine what
where the cost and benefit is for either
using one modality or the other alone or
in combination and then lastly whether
or not MRI and genomic tests can be used
to reduce or increase surveillance
intensity so there is a large push
towards reducing the number of
unnecessary biopsies and MRI data as
well as genomic testing data could
potentially help us tailor a module
the intensity of surveillance for
patient so that we can minimize biopsies
and the attendant side-effects so thank
you very much for attending this talk I
appreciate your time and if you have any
questions feel free to contact me thank
you